can't rat now
wrestling with Satan you know Satan that
villain from new Doctor Who season 2
episode 9 you see five unaired scripts
from the new Doctor Who Season eight
have leaked and they're only a few
clicks away and now they're on my hard
drive
what a dilemma I don't want to spoil my
viewing experience but on the other hand
I'd love to point out everything that's
wrong with these new episodes before
anyone's had a chance to see them should
I read the PDFs or should I trash them
read or trash oh if only the galaxy
would give me some sort of a sign
uh-huh look I need a clear sign
something unambiguous Doctor Who fans
are split into two camps the clueless
noobs who think that the show began in
2005 and the nostalgic fogies who think
that the show has been going downhill
since the late 70s when Tom Baker was a
doctor and Douglas Adams was a script
editor and the special effects budget
was two pounds eight shillings per
episode well guess what neither side is
right I'll grab the fogies at Tom Baker
is worth two David Tennant's in a Matt
Smith and that Douglas Adams is worth
eight Russell T Davies and 22 Steven
Moffat
but new who has some of the greatest
companions ever and companions are the
secret ingredient to the show's success
the best companions embody some trade
that the current incarnation of the Time
Lord lacks a companion could be Fair
Isle and honky when the doctor is old
and feeble or they can be apply the book
stickler when the doctor is an impish
roguish okie toting bad ass when the
doctor is non confrontational and
manipulative Donna Noble was an
outspoken hoot continually upstaging
Tennant no matter how much he flashed
his maniacal grin and she actually
became a badass Time Lord what an Amy
Pond grounded the Tenth Doctor as he
swung wildly from tortured bleakness to
frolicsome childishness Clara traveled
through time fixing flaws in every
season of the show ways of running to
save the doctor again and again and
again now that's my kind of sci-fi
superstar now granted the writers failed
Martha Jones and Rose Tyler totally
overrated yeah I said it see letting her
run off to a parallel universe with the
clone of the Tenth Doctor is exactly the
sort of pandering fanservice that I hate
that is exactly the sort of fanservice
that doesn't
to me do you think Capaldi will be a
good doctor
my take is that he cannot be the doctor
because he was already a Roman guy in
season 4 episode 2 and hey isn't that
Amy Pond playing his daughter what are
they trying to pull here let me know
your least favorite companion in the
comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel